if there's some questions that are
probably going to be of interest
everybody will save those for the end
and you answer them with answers to
questions and the questions themselves
we'll make them available in a Q&A
document that's going to be linked to
our webinars and courses page on the FTP
site in the materials directory the
materials directory is given to you
there as a compressed URL ok so I'm
going to turn this over to Rana now
she's going to talk to you about api's
so thanks for joining us today today is
a little different than our usual NCBI
minutes it's gonna be a little longer
we're gonna be talking about api's that
have been developed at ncbi and really
this is an introduction to ncbi api's
for people who are new to api's and for
those who are already API savvy just to
give you an idea of the diversity and
breadth of API is available at NCBI and
where to look for more information for
those of you who are already using API
such as the e-utilities you may not
learn too much in this particular talk
but we do want to hear from you and are
really interested on if you are
interested want to learn more if you
have a specific questions about how to
use a particular API or problems with
the script you've already developed
please send a message into the help desk
and we will work directly with you to
help you with your script after this
webinar we're going to be sending a
survey to ask everybody for feedback
we're really interested in what specific
API topics you'd like to learn more
about or in more detail and what
functionality or access to specific
types of data at NCBI you'd like to have
added to our existing repertoire of
api's also if you have other ideas let
us know we'd really like to hear from
you
so for beginners what is an API and what
can it do for you just to give a quick
set of definitions URLs which you
probably already know about our web
addresses and they're composed of two
main components of protocol identifiers
HTTP or the secure HTTP FTP SFTP and a
resource name such as the NCBI URL or
the blast URL and those will get you
direct links into our servers
api's are URLs with specifics in taxes
that have been designed for developers
to use with in their scripts or
applications or programs to interact
with servers across the internet NCBI is
api's have been developed for
third-party developers to access process
and retrieve data from our back-end
servers we're also using our own
services now pubchem as an example they
are using our own api's but there are
other commercial companies and other
people who are using api's including
endnote biogps there's a molecules app
on the iPad and more I'm gonna describe
api's again for theaters as kind of an
action-based sentence with specific
romantical parts I'll show you how to do
this in just a minute
with our most popular API that so many
people are using what I'm going to cover
today are really four specific api's
that we have there's a whole bunch more
at NCBI I want to show you where to find
the information on these and and then
I'll show you where you can keep up and
find out more information in general
we'll also talk about edirect a little
bit at the end which is not really an
API but uses api's and might be an
alternative for you if you actually
don't want to write your own scripts but
you actually want to be able to process
information from our back-end servers so
our most popular API is virtually
site-wide it's almost all of our
databases all of our entre databases and
it's called the entre programming
utilities sometimes called the
e-utilities some kind of times called
the e utils this is a set of structured
URL calls to access our databases and I
will show you examples coming up as to
how to use these there are about 25
million utils calls that are actually
sent to our servers every single day
from about a hundred thousand different
IP addresses this is actually even a
little more than is actually hitting
from our front end servers but we have a
lot more people who use those about 4.2
million people who use our web services
every day that are actually making about
21 million calls so this is actually a
very popular resource there
types of things you can do and these are
only a small set of examples you could
search PubMed with a term and retrieve
the PubMed identifier z' you could
search medgen with a sno-med CT ID you
can then link over to GTR retrieve the
summary information for the genetic
tests that are related to that sno-med
CT ID you could post a list of gene IDs
and fetch their full records or even
post a pubchem compound cid and you can
actually see what the the molecule looks
like we've got a lot of information
about the utils there is a book and I'm
going to show you a bigger slide to
figure out where you can get the
information as to how to use these
things there are also two YouTube videos
that are already on our YouTube site
ones only four minutes long to give you
a quick introduction and one is a full
hour that will give you a whole lot more
detail then those are the links there
the key thing about the utils is the
base URL and I'll show you this in a
little bit but anytime you see utils in
the URL you'll notice that that happens
to be calling our utils API so this is
the book of instructions to help you
figure out how to use the e-utilities
and as a matter of fact if we've got a
table of contents on the right hand side
this is on our bookshelf it's got an
introduction it's got a whole
description of all the different
utilities and even some sample
applications and even some scripts to
show you as examples how to use them the
key to using any API is not only to know
which server to hit but also where to
operate in our case we think of it as
kind of a noun in a sentence is where to
operate what kind of database or what
kind of data do you want to get this is
an example from our G query page that
shows you all the different databases
that we have inhabited CBI there's
actually more but this is most of them
and it's a wide diversity of different
types of data that we happen to have and
the utilities actually works pretty much
in all of our entre databases now here's
your base URL again with your utils and
that's what you want to use for every
single call
for an API involving the e-utilities but
you do need to add a couple of things to
your sentences you need to have verbs
that tell you what you want to do and
then nouns with what so as an example in
that little red box there you can put a
verb which is these are examples of some
of the nine different calls that you can
make to tell the e utility what to do
you could do a search you could post you
could create a summary you could grab a
fetch a record you could even link
between databases and then you need a
noun to tell you what are you starting
off with I have a text query that I want
to perform a search with I have a set of
ID's that I want to post or that I want
to grab the e summaries from or I want
to fetch the whole record or I want a
link from one set of IDs to a database
and I want to get something back on the
other end and these are the things that
you get on the other end from these
particular verbs here's an example let's
say you want to get a summary of
information about a gene and you know
the gene ID which happens to be 3 2 6 9
that app happens to be the ID for the
human histamine receptor h1 and here's
how to structure one of the utility's
api's you've got your base URL call
which will identify the server that you
want to go to utils you have a verb in
this case any summary get me the east
summary for this particular record I
want to go in this particular database
and I want to use this particular term
you can also specify what the format is
but right now we're gonna go with the
default and we'll show you what the
default is in a minute so it's kind of
hard to see but this is if you copy
paste the URL and put it into a web
browser you get back a structured list
here in XML which happens to be our
default that shows you what you get back
which is the east summary in XML format
for the human histamine receptor h1 from
the gene database another example could
be trying to find pubmed record IDs for
this gene ID now in our
gene database we happen to actually be
able to link directly from the gene to
records in PubMed that have been
identified as referring to this
particular gene so I'm only showing you
the first half the the back half of the
API call you and you still use the same
base call all the way up here through
utils in blue and then instead of the
nice summary you would actually use the
verb elink you want to link from one
database from gene database to to
another one in this case PubMed and
we're gonna start off with our input as
our ID again 3 2 6 9 so this is kind of
what it looks like and again it's an XML
which is the standard format again we
can change the format so I'll show you
that coming up but we actually starting
off with a DB from gene DB to PubMed
here's your ID 3 2 6 9 and then these
are different
PubMed identifiers that correspond to
that particular gene record now I showed
you things in XML and I showed you east
summaries but we can actually change the
format of how we get things back maybe
you don't like XML maybe you'd rather
have a different format you can do that
in the utilities by using the RET type
parameter and then specifying what you
want to return it as XML was the
defaults if you don't say anything
you'll get the default so this is what
it looks like here's a nice summary from
PubMed for a particular ID this happens
to be one of the IDS we saw before and
again you will see over here in the in
the screen below this long XML with all
the authors and the title and the
information that happens to be in the
summary information about that
particular ID if you add ret type at the
end an orange here and you say MEDLINE
you'll actually get it back in MEDLINE
format and a lot of the librarians who
happen to be on the line might be very
familiar with you the mid line format or
in this particular case we're doing an e
fetch and a fetch here is getting the
entire record which includes the
abstract you won't have the abstract in
your summary but you can also get that
back in it
some le can either specify it with XML
or if you don't put the ret type in
you'll automatically get back in XML
now these utils calls are really most
useful not just individually but they're
useful for EU til pipelines in other
words you could start off with one util
call and daisy-chain it to another and
another and another to actually do
something useful so here's an example of
one you could do let's say you're
starting off with a disease hereditary
haemochromatosis which happens to have a
particular sno-med CT ID and you want to
do a search in our Disney in our disease
database medgen so we're gonna do any
search in medgen and that will get us
back a set of medgen identifiers or id's
but let's say you really want to find
not just the medgen id's but you want to
find things in another database you want
to find it in the genetic testing
registry to find out if there are any
genetic tests for hereditary
haemochromatosis so what you can do then
is actually take those med gen id's and
use a link to go from Meghan those IDs
into GTR or the genetic testing registry
that will get you back a bunch of GTR or
genetic testing registry identifiers and
then the identifier czar nice but you'd
like to get some human readable
information so you can then pull the
easte summary of those GTR ids and then
in the summary information you're gonna
be able to get who is giving the test
who to contact they even have names in
them so you can make three utilities
calls and start off with one I input and
get something hopefully very useful out
now the book on the bookshelf for the
entre programming utilities has lots and
lots of examples and in fact they have a
lot of examples of these utility calls
as well the important thing to know is
that you can hit our servers and we'd
love you to use this it actually helps
us and helps our users but we do need
you to respect all the different other
people who are also accessing our
servers so we have some usage guidelines
we'd like you to stick by we'd like you
to limit the URL request to less than
three calls per se
and if you've got a really really large
job let's say you've got a whole huge
list of ID's we'd like you to actually
limit the large jobs that you enter to
weekdays weekends or weekdays Eastern
Standard Time in the evenings and at
night that way more and more people can
access our servers without having too
much traffic we do have to warn you that
if you do not comply with this policy
you could be blocked until we can talk
with you and actually try to help you
resolve the issue most of the time it's
just that one little tweak fixes the
problem but if we don't know what that
is we can't help you so one of the
things you can currently do is send an
email to our utilities email address
letting us know what the name of your
tool and your email address is and
include that in your utility call and so
if there are problems with your scripts
we have an email address and we'll try
to contact you before we actually block
you you don't use that information or
put that information in there we have no
idea what we do is we just find the
closest IP address that we can to the
one that's sending the script and we
have to block it coming up though
anticipated late March April of 2018
we're going to be initiating a brand new
utilities API registration system that
will allow you to actually register your
own email address and your API and we'll
give you an API key that you can just
use in all your URL calls that will help
us better manage our services but we're
gonna give you a bonus for doing it
we're gonna allow you to actually make
call rates even a little faster than
three per second so hopefully it will
help you out as well we will have more
and more information as we get closer to
that date about how to access it how to
register and and what you need to do in
order to do that there are lots of other
API tools at NCBI one of the ones that
many people haven't quite heard about is
one of a suite of pubmed central tools
that have been developed to help people
who are actually using our PubMed
Central or PMC database there is one in
particular
called the ID converter which I think
might be helpful for a lot of people if
you are submitting a manuscript because
you have NIH funding or even those from
PMC Canada or you're submitting things
to PMC in Europe you may want to take
your manuscript
ID and find out what the PM's the final
PMC ID is once it's in there
you can even correlate PMC IDs with PM
IDs or again for the librarian crew out
there even the digital object
identifiers the duis we have the art
this works specifically for articles
that are listed in PMC
not everything that in PubMed will work
only if they actually have an article in
PMC
so examples of things you can do let's
say you have an NIH msid because you
submitted it in as part of your grant
processing you can then find the PMC ID
or the pmid for that you can correlate
p.m. IDs with PMC IDs which have free
full-text articles or even find the duis
now there is a base URL for the PMC ID
converter as well and you notice it
doesn't have utils in it it actually has
PMC as the database and ID com because
this is the ID converter and that's the
beginning of all of URL calls you would
use for this particular API where to
learn more here in fact I'm going to
show you this
there is a PMC developer resources page
here's the URL at / PMC slash tool slash
developers and there's all sorts of
different api's they have developed with
the pubmed central group the ID
converter will actually get you to a
page that tells you how to use the
information as well I've got a number of
different examples again it's very
similar to the e utility calls but the
major difference is that the base URL is
a little different and then again the
parameters are slightly different and
you can again find your information back
in regular XML but other formats as well
things like HTML JSON or even a CSV
format that you can download I'm not
going to go through exam
but on our FTP site if you look for the
URL that go usa.gov place I actually
have all of these things worked out with
screenshots so you can actually take a
look if you copy paste these directly
into a browser you can see what it
actually looks like usage guidelines the
PMC crew would like you to know that you
can actually add a lot of different
identifiers x' in each individual
request it can have more than one but
don't mix the types of the ids the api
doesn't work in that case in other words
if you're starting off with nih ms ids
just stick a whole bunch of nihm s ids
in one row do not mix an nih MS with a
pubmed with the DOI is an example and
you can use up to 200 ids in a single
request you can just daisy chain those
together with commas if you have a
larger number of ideas split it up so
that you do have less than 200 per call
if you have a really large set of ID's
though there's actually a file on the
ftp site you might want to take a look
at where it actually does a direct
correlation of PMC ids with nih ms lifts
pubmed with DOI another API at ncbi and
this is probably our second most popular
is blast and the blast calls it blasts
URL API this will allow you to actually
run sequence similarity searches
remotely on our servers it's a
three-step process and you have to do
all three otherwise you won't get your
results back you submit the job to the
servers tell them what you want them to
do then you have to let the blast
calculations actually process you want
to check the information to see if the
job is done and then you once the job is
actually done you can actually retrieve
the information there's lots of things
you can do you can search for an
identical or near identical sequence to
find out more about it you can look for
potential homologs you can find where a
sequence may match a sequence on a
genome for annotation purposes and lots
of more things with with blast the blast
URL base
API base here again has blast in it and
then blasts CGI again this will identify
a blast URL API call as opposed to one
from the utilities or the PubMed Central
ID converter and we've got lots of
information on blast I'll show you how
to find this on our blast home page
there is actually a help link in the
upper right hand corner if you click on
it you can get lots of information about
blast in general on the right hand side
over here is developer information which
gets you to a page that will help you
learn to use our developer tools
including our blasts restful interfaces
clicking on one of the documentation
links will actually take you over to a
github page and our github page actually
gives you all the information about the
URL API and also see more information at
running web blasts all the different
parameters to customize your blast
searches are listed on that page as well
so again just like the PMC ID converter
api's i'm actually not going to go
through this specific example but the
slides are available on the FTP site
which actually steps through each of
these processes submitting a query in
this particular case we're going to try
to find sequences that are similar to
the human acetylcholinesterase in the
PDB database which happens to be a
structure database we're gonna use the
blastp program and again the database is
PDB the most important point that i want
to make here is the usage guidelines for
our blast api's you can submit calls and
we'd like you because of the intense
nature of the calculations to keep our
calls three seconds apart for the
initiation of each of your searches
probably more important than anything
else is for the second step where you
have to check on the progress of your
blast search with the AR ID or request
identifier you need to let the blast
search actually perform its calculations
before you check so please consider a
delay between step one and step two for
at least
one minute to let the blast search
actually do its thing and then after you
search you're looking for a status
equals ready to let you know that the
calculation is done if that's not there
then you can check again and we again
request that you put a 30-second spacer
or so in between each subsequent check
once the ready status exists you can go
ahead and get your results and there are
a lot of different formats you can get
them in from text XML even to a really
cool tabular format finally please limit
your web blast searches to less than a
hundred searches per day if you need to
do a bunch more than that we've actually
created a service called blast in the
cloud which you can find on that github
page which will allow you to either use
your scripts against the blast servers
in the cloud or you can actually use
blast yourself in the cloud
our third API that I want to hit today
is specifically designed for our
chemical database pubchem and they call
our pubchem api pug rest again this is a
set of structured URL calls it's very
restful and there are two main types of
pug rest calls one of them and you can
see the base URLs on the right-hand side
of this page they both start off with
pubchem that's how you know they're
pubchem api's one of them is says pug
view and the other one is just pug I'm
going to show you the difference from
them in just a second but different
examples of things you can do is you can
search for chemical synonyms let's say
you've got propanol and you want to know
what all the different names for
propanol are or tamoxifen or estrogen or
estrogen find chemical properties for
particular chemicals things like
molecular weight you could get whole
sections of pubchem compound records
let's say you've got tamoxifen and you
want to know what the pharmacology
information is or if you've got
diethylstilbestrol you want to know what
the toxicology information is you can
pull that down from full full sections
out of the record you can even see the
two-dimensional structure for a chemical
with a single URL call which is pretty
cool there's a lot of information
and a lot of examples and the Pug rest
help documentation how to find that from
the pubchem homepage under the services
tab there is a link to pug rest which
has a lot of text information it's a
very very long document but here's just
the beginning of the table of contents
that will actually help you step through
the process of creating these URLs so
there's a number of different URLs and
again the examples that are here are
worked out in the peep the PowerPoint
that and PDF that are on the FTP site
the Pug view URL and it's listed right
here with the URL pug view slash data
will allow you to pull out whole
sections of a pubchem compound record it
as an example you use the headings from
the tables of compounds from the record
to get all the synonyms for compound
identifiers 3 1 0 0 which by the way
happens to be diphenhydramine or
benadryl
you could also look for a different
heading mesh pharmacological
classifications is a very very helpful
section to talk about all the different
possible pharmacological actions that
this particular chemical diphenhydramine
has notice that we've got JSON here they
had they provide formats of JSON and XML
and a number of others as well the
caveat for the Pug view which will pull
out whole sections individual sections
of the pubchem compound records is that
it only works with the IDs or compound
identifies in other words this number 3
1 0 0 how do you find the compound
identifier let's say you've got the name
Benadryl and you want to look something
up you can either use the e-utilities
remember I mentioned the utilities work
with virtually all over databases or you
can use the other type of Pug rest api
that's called Pug which will allow you
to do more than just this CF compound
identifier as an example here here it
says just rest Pug not Pug view compound
which is the name of the database name
and benadryl name is the type of input
you have here benadryl you can get back
the see IDs in the text information you
can get lots of information including
concatenated stuff as well as the
pictures usage guidelines again please
keep them less than five requests per
second and if you want large sets of
information the pubchem FTP so it
actually has a lot of that on the FTP
site finally I just want to introduce
you very very quickly to an alternative
for people who really really want the
data but they really don't want to do
the scripting you can use a thing called
entre direct or a direct a direct is
actually not an API in its of itself
it's a suite of applications that
actually use the entre programming
utilities the utilities and lots of
information about how to use the e
direct tools are not only on our
bookshelf and we happen to have on our
an e direct cookbook that will allow you
to see examples but we also have
training programs webinars and courses
those are hyperlinks that you can get to
as well as for part 10 to 15-minute
YouTube videos that have been put out by
our PubMed customer services group as
well and as a matter of fact we're
teaching more courses on it Peter Cooper
will be teaching a course and edirect
on the 18th of September at the NIH here
if you happen to be in the Bethesda or
DC metro area the big thing about
edirect is that you use line commands
for it you don't use URLs you don't have
to write scripts and as a matter of fact
you can customize what you get back it's
not just searching for what is in the
database and retrieving it but a even
able to parse it reformat it and then
download it yourself how to find
information about edirect it's actually
in the entre programming the utilities
book that you saw before it's actually a
whole chapter that's just on trade Iraq
and then the entre direct cookbook on
github actually has lots and lots of
examples and we're accumulating more Ben
Busby is coordinating this effort with
his hackathon program just to let you
know we have a number of other api's the
variations services
sequence position deletion insertion or
speedy api's will allow you to play with
the different variation servers that we
have here at NCBI
the genome remapping service is very
similar to the entree direct and that
it's actually a perl script that you
download and allows you to help
coordinate mapping from one genomic
assembly to another alright that's a lot
of information how do I keep up with all
of this from our NCBI home site we have
a little thing there called develop
which will take you to a developer site
to give you more information than you
probably ever need about our tools
including our api's which are listed
there which gives you a whole page for
our api's and we're gonna be updating
this set of API is actually very shortly
to add more and more so I'm wrapping up
now as you may imagine we've got lots
and lots of resources here at the NCBI
and also at the National Library of
Medicine as well where they have
additional api's that you might be
interested in here's a URL where you can
find out more about all the api's that
the National Library of Medicine
provides and again we are going to be
we're in the process of cataloging not
just these api's but even more that we
have at the at the NCBI and we're going
to be putting them on that develop page
that you actually just saw there are
webinars like this and courses like
Peters the e direct course to help and
you can get those on the NCBI it's not
lean site but learn site for more
information and we're also want you to
introduce you to the concept of
hackathons where scripters will use
api's to create specific tools then
Buzzbee is actually coordinating one in
Pittsburgh coming up at the end of
September that will actually enlist the
use of api's in order to help create
really cool tools there's lots of
information that I've covered these are
the base URLs for all the help
documentation for each individual API I
talked about today we also have an NCBI
insights blog where a lot of things are
posted about api's and other serve
and CBI and of course our YouTube
website we have a the email address for
help with all of ncbi resources
including the api's that you may be
using and the ftp site for lots of data
as well and encourage you to send
messages in so that we can help you
actually learn to use the api's
effectively and that's it thank you very
much for listening and all the
information will be on our FTP site we
look forward to hearing from you on the
survey as well to help guide us in
providing more and better and more
targeted information about what we have
at NCBI and api's in specific thank you
okay thanks Ron uh I don't think we have
a whole lot of time for questions and
I've answered most of the ones that were
fairly straightforward in the questions
pod and think everyone should know the
answers there's one question in here
that I don't think we may not know the
answer to this but I thought I'd throw
it out there to rana see if she knows
anything about this somebody asks about
the things that work for pmc also going
to work for the nasa nist and DHS
repositories on PMC do you have any
ideas about that I'll definitely check
on that with the PMC folks from what I
understand if these things happen to be
at NCBI in the PMC database they should
work if there are in other sources I
can't guarantee it we will ask the
question and we'll add it to that QA
document so that you'll be able to find
that information out as well
okay thanks your honor and so I will put
these there have been a few questions
most of them are fairly specific and
straightforward but I'll make sure we
have those in the Q&A document that's
going to be up and people were asking
about you know the slides and they
recording all those things are available
on the materials directory also it's in
the questions module as well if you have
questions about the webinar you can
write the webinars at NCBI NLM des and
IH like of general questions about ncbi
resources please write the info at NCBI
NLM NIH Scott thanks everybody for
coming
you